I first heard about Genesis from a
documentary that had been made about him
and I was I was sent this by the the
producer of the film and he said to me
you got to check this guy out he's
amazing so I watched it and I was
actually in LA here at the time and he
was New Zeeland and he sort of sent me
this very low res file and everyone's
face was kind of like one pixel but even
then after about 20 minutes I was
booking my flight back to New Zealand
because I was so blown away by him as a
person he was such an incredible
combination of intelligence
he was so articulate he was in such a
fascinating worldview and philosophy but
he was also riddled with contradictions
he was there was such a massive
complexity to him as a character so I
immediately wanted to meet him so I flew
back to New Zealand
and myself and Tom went down to gibbon
and we went to Jeanne's house and of
course he he didn't let us down at all
when I when we arrived and when I first
walked in he was standing there wearing
pink Crocs like the ones that are in the
film which immediately made Ben know I
had to get those in the film and and he
did a kind of a nunchuck thing there any
of these strange tights and we kind of
did know what to say and then after that
I sat down with him over a chess board
and I think that was the moment that we
really first kind of bonded because I've
played chess since I was a kid so I
quickly lost to him but not too quickly
that I didn't manage to get a little
kernel of his respect and he kind of
began to open up and from there we
played hundreds and hundreds of games
and we just talked and we talked all
about his life and his experiences and
as I say he had an incredibly eloquent
way of describing you know his struggles
with his mental health and all sorts of
his experiences so I began writing the
script I was very sort of blessed to
know gin for about the last year of his
life so for the initial period I was
really just wanting to know more about
him and as I say I was kind of like
putting together of a vast array of the
different facets of this man's life and
thinking about the way to approach
telling his story and there was the
obvious kind of
narrative aspect of the the club and the
kids in this tournament but which which
kind of was a way of stringing things
together but for me I was much more
drawn to and fascinated by Jin's own
sort of inner struggle and you know his
also his ability to kind of communicate
with these kids through chess so not so
much in the end ultimately about whether
they're great chess players or not or
you know even if they win a tournament
or not but instead what he can actually
try and use his own his own hardship and
his own struggles he's been through to
not only try and rise above that but to
use that to actually you know help
others around him it's a cliff can you
talk a little bit about preparing to
play a character who's actually you know
a living person versus is there are
different different preparations from
when you're creating a character sort of
from whole cloth absolutely the you know
the relationship with fictional
characters between you and the page and
you're given license and permission by
the director to interpret the writers
work it's pretty obvious that there's an
obligation to a living person but to
give you a sense I never got to meet him
likewise I saw the documentary and it
enthralled and intrigued but it was when
I went to his hometown and I met with
his family made his wife his son the
other characters that are portrayed in
the film Noble and the Jedi and they got
me in a car and we went up for a small
Drive and we pulled into a graveyard and
they stood me at the grave site of Jen
and it was just a very clear message to
me how cherished and beloved he was to
them so it was a personal
relationship then there wasn't something
I was interpreting from James's work on
the page though I now had my own direct
personal relationship with him his son
his wife and his two dearest friends
basically his family and I was from that
moment beholding to them so did the
Jen's family continue to collaborate
with you as you went into production
absolutely and that was one of the
things that was quite sort of tough
there was a very very tough moment there
because when we lost Jean when he passed
away as I say I've been working on it
for about a year and it was no one saw
that coming it was it was a real shock
and suddenly the film went from being
you know a movie about this guy that you
know could come to the premiere and you
know I could sit there and look at him
and have a laugh and you know what did
you think
suddenly now this is going to become as
legacy people will define him as this
this will be what he is remembered for
essentially if the film manages to do
what it what it should do and with that
suddenly there was an immense amount of
pressure but also meant that his friends
and his very close friends and his
family had to step and kind of help to
make sure that we were doing it justice
so we had them on set every day when we
were shooting to make sure that
everything we were doing was kind of
authentic and and respectful they were
you know the first people to show a cut
too and and it was a very you know
stressful moment when they saw it
because you know it was really important
to do justice to these people's lives
knowing that they wouldn't as I say be
kind of held accountable to it in a way
so if they hadn't liked it if they
hadn't enjoyed that screening I knew
there were some very tough moments for
us because I didn't want to I didn't
want to disrespect that but thankfully
they they loved it and they were
incredibly you know supportive so while
you were while you're shooting on
location they're looking at the film it
looks like basically it was shot
entirely with handheld cameras so cliff
could you talk a little bit about that
that style and how that impacted the the
performance and and how you tackle each
scene
James could probably speak a little bit
more about the technical aspects of it
but how it made the process for me for
us I think fluid as much as possible in
terms of how he moved through the space
and how he related to the environment
and we related to each other and so
that's always a plus but to qualify that
James also encouraged me to approach the
role from the place as a method act
which I'd never done before and so that
was a that was a really of challenging
there were a couple of really close
calls there where I could have taken out
the cameraman and the and and and the
and the camera moments there with the
car were the ones absolutely absolutely
and and when I was trying to get me in
the van they were it was the couple of
moments there where where yeah where
thankfully they weren't on tripods they
could actually move and to talk about
that quickly because I think again when
we were starting to discuss this you
know the the potential of off cliff
trying to inhabit the role and it sort
of became apparent that I mean you look
at cliff right now and here's a sort of
very slim handsome you know leading man
in Genesis as you have just seen the
picture was a big guy with funny
haircuts and missing teeth and you know
all these incredible beautiful
eccentricities so it was like what
with such an extreme character what is
an extreme way to approach it to try and
get in there and so cliff ended up
putting on about close to 60 pounds in
you know not much more than six weeks
and what's your secret no no it actually
took me longer than that took me months
but most of it was in the last six weeks
because I was watching terrified waiting
because I thought people would have
asked me it were you worried about
cliffs health and I was like no not
really I was more worried if he was
gonna be fat enough on the first day of
filming because you know it's really
like you know excited idea of a
beautiful robust cliff and thankfully we
got there yeah well I was getting a
little bit what I was attempting to put
the weight on
over a period of like three to six
months and I was getting some weight on
there was you know I'm middle-aged so it
wasn't that hard to get some weight on
but to get over the decline I had to I
had to employ a very specific technique
it's called beer that's and also the
other thing I was struggling with was
trying to reduction loves by the way yo
yeah insurance and trying to wrap my
head around the game of chess so the
beer served a dual purpose it helped me
transform physically I'm gonna help me
and enjoy the game purchase immensely
beer in chess oh yeah comment might not
commonly put the two together it really
doesn't make it a lot more fun there was
how work with the real gin as well I
mean it like a lot of my games you know
I mean Jen had this incredible way he'd
get a box of Stein ease and Stein lager
beers and he would drink them while we'd
be playing and of course I would sort of
meekly try and keep up and fail
miserably and as it finished each beer
he'd stack them in like a chess like
format okay with empty bottles so you
know there's this feel just things like
I mean you kind of like embrace that and
that helped with the weight and yes it
was I was hitting I was hitting
somewhere between two a dozen to two
dozen beers a day and cliffs not a
drinker by the way just you know
seriously so so that was um there was a
sacrifice there but the other one the
other sacrifice was I asked this this
very very committed man here to
essentially stay in character for the
entirety of the shoot and that was
something that neither of us i was not
keen no i won't you weren't at all no at
all in fact both those things when i
asked you to put the weight on and stand
you were like no that's not gonna but
you see this was interesting because it
comes back to your first question
because if it was just my role to
interpret i wouldn't have put on the
weight and i probably would not have
gone through the method things i have a
family they're just technical issues of
like how do I stay in character and have
a discussion about marks and camera and
I was like how do you do that it was
very challenging for me but I headed to
that was a character being
who's psychologically was on the edge he
was on the precipice each day and I
lived like that like for my from for a
long time months a long time and that's
but this is I mean that being Hawes it
was a real person and because I had an
obligation to honor who he was and the
struggles it just organically became the
only choice and so how was so how was
that relating to the other actors
because my understanding is that there
was a mixture of both professional
actors and non actors in the yeah I mean
I look a lot of the act a lot of the
actors that never act before so the the
the guy that plays our turkey the
brother in the film
he'd never acted before in his life we
actually found him in a winds office in
New Zealand which is like a benefit kind
of unemployment office we'd put a sign
up there saying we were looking for
marty men in their 40s a good daily rate
tattoos and criminal records welcomed
and so we had a queue down the block and
wayne happened to be one of those people
that threw his hat in the ring and from
the first he kind of put something small
down on tape that our wonderful casting
director of it when it did and
immediately it seemed like there's
something there you know there was
something special about this guy but
he's never acted before he doesn't have
an agent he doesn't even have a phone
number at that point and so a vet kind
of was like you know but i think you
should really you know take take a
closer look and i kind of felt that as
well so i thought well let's throw him
in the deep end and make him read the
toughest scene in the film opposite
cliff i found out later that wayne had
to catch i think there's like three bus
rides to get there a couple of hours of
constant stops he walks in and right
from the very first take was exceptional
and and from that point on he was he was
exceptional he's an extremely
intelligent guy and just had incredible
instincts for someone that had never
done it before thank you so much for
joining us